all right we start tonight with breaking
news there is a second memo exposing
deep state corruption
now senators Chuck Grassley and Lindsey
Graham have released a heavily redacted
yet very revealing copy of their
criminal referral against Christopher
Steele now these revelations are beyond
stunning and continue to prove the
Clinton campaign and the Obama
administration were working together to
target the Trump campaign here are the
findings from this new memo this is just
released today
not the old memo on Friday we've got to
keep up here now senators Grassley and
Graham write this that while working on
a second dossier Steele was being fed
information from the Obama State
Department and from Clinton allies the
memo then reads and goes on quote one
memorandum by mr. Steele that was not
published by BuzzFeed is dated October
19 2016 the report alleges redacted as
well as redacted mr. Steele's memorandum
states that his company received this
report from redacted US State Department
and that the report was the second in a
series and that the report was
information that came from a foreign
subsys who is in touch with a contact of
redacted a friend of the Clintons who
passed the to redacted and it's
troubling enough that the Clinton
campaign funded mr. Steele's work but
that these Clinton associates were
contemporaneously feeding mr. Steele's
allegations
it raises huge additional concerns about
his credibility now let me slow down
here in addition to Hillary Clinton
buying and paying a bought and paid for
12-plus million-dollar phony fake news
Russian propaganda dossier to influence
the election if that's not bad enough
you have now Clinton associates and the
Obama State Department funneling
allegations for a second dossier -
Christopher Steele now watch the second
part in terms of the new memo that came
out today now on the face the dossier it
appears that mr. Steele gathered much of
his information let's do this really
slow from Russian government sources
insider Russia and according to the law
firm Perkins Coie mr. Steele's dossier
related
efforts were funded through fusion GPS
by that law firm on behalf of the
Democratic National Committee and the
Clinton campaign so the Senators are
saying that steel was using Russian
sources to help them smear
then-candidate and later on incoming
president Donald Trump and the second
memo is also accusing Christopher Steele
of lying to either the FBI or to the
British courts they write quote there is
substantial evidence suggesting that mr.
Steele materially misled the FBI about a
key aspect of his dossier efforts one
which bears on his credibility as if we
didn't know now there's new memo out
tonight also details how Christopher
Steele was briefing several mainstream
media outlets fake news outlets in the
summer and the fall of 2016 about his
first fake news dossier now according to
the British Court records Steele briefed
of the New York Times The Washington
Post Yahoo News The New Yorker and of
course the OL Network fake news CNN at
the end of September 2016 about the
dossier that we know is full of lives so
Steele was feeding the destroyed Trump
media lies directly from Russia and we
also know from fusion GPS co-founder
Glenn Simpson and his congressional
testimony that the Clinton campaign and
the DNC were aware that his company was
contacting media outlets about the
dossier they're all working together so
let me repeat tonight we now had two
memos one from Friday and one from
tonight and now news of a second we'll
call it a dossier now as we told you on
Friday this new information I told you
fright was only 15 percent it's only the
tip of the iceberg now according to
reports the House Intelligence Committee
Chairman Devin Nunez while he could
release more reports as many as four
will ask him tonight he will join us
exclusively on this program
responding to the new memo that is out
and Senator Chuck Grassley and Senator
Graham they're trying to get more of
what's in their memo Declassified
they're asking the FBI for an emergency
review of the criminal referral and also
brand-new tonight on Hannity the House
Intelligence Committee did vote to
release the Democrats counter memo to
the public and sources have been telling
us tonight
that congressman Adam Schiff the
Democratic ranking member in the House
Intelligence Committee he is outright
lying to the American people about what
is in the Democrats counter to the Nunez
memo it gets confusing but it makes
sense now ship also appears to be
leaking classified information let's
watch this it is relevant information to
alert the FISA Court is there a
political motivation was there political
actor involved and the court was
notified political actor was involved
and that's part of the misleading nature
of the finds application in terms of the
identity of the political actor the most
important information for the court is
what did Christopher still know and Glen
Stinson has testified the Christopher
steel was not told the identity of the
lawyer or the party behind the lawyer
that's the most important information of
value and Christopher Steele's bias hey
Adam did you tell the court was the
court told that this was bought and paid
for by the Clintons in the DNC that's
why ship is wrong on so many different
levels now sources are telling us
tonight the contrary to whatever fiction
ship is peddling the FISA Court was lied
to they were never told when the FBI was
getting and then renewing this warrant
to spy on former Trump campaign adviser
Carter page those same sources are
telling us tonight that ships claim
about the court being informed that the
dossier was politically tainted it is a
minor footnote it never mentions that
Hillary and her campaign in the DNC paid
for it Oh
a pretty important omission don't you
think and we can also report tonight
according to our sources who have seen
this Democratic memo that nothing in the
memo actually refutes any of the facts
that were presented in the House GOP
Intel memo which by the way we told you
on Friday and the FBI said there's
nothing factually inaccurate about it so
here's what the left and your corrupt
media won't tell you tonight
the FISA judge was never told never that
Hillary Clinton was paying for that bony
Russian dossier Russian intelligence
lies about Donald Trump first trying to
influence an election and then using it
to get a warrant to spy on an opposition
candidate the Democratic memo has not
been Declassified yet and ship is going
around telling anybody who will listen
what's in it in other words he's leaking
classified information now President
Trump is
lasting rightly so ship on Twitter
writing earlier today little Adam Schiff
who is desperate to run for higher
office is one of the biggest liars and
leakers in Washington right up there
with Comey and Warner and Brennan and
clapper and Adam leaves clothes
committee hearings to illegally leaked
confidential information this should and
must be stopped
I actually disagree with President Trump
ship is actually auditioning he wants a
job a conspiracy TV MSNBC kind of like
commis assistant just got hired by fake
new CNN now another breaking news
tonight this is important Sarah Carter
reporting that Schiff is leading a media
campaign along with former Obama
administration officials and Democrats
to attack
congressman Devin Nunez and the
four-page memo now this fierce
opposition is not surprising but as
everyone involved in this deep state
effort to spy on the Trump campaign and
to damage and destroy a duly elected
president as of tonight I can promise
you they are all scared out of their
minds because they are being exposed you
know here's what Democrats and these
high-ranking officials well they don't
want you to know about that details in
the Nunez memo and here are the major
revelations we learned this Friday
former deputy FBI director Andrew McCabe
testified before Congress that without
the dossier the FISA warrant to spy on
the Trump campaign Carter page never
would have been approved by the way I
have sources confirming that is true
tonight and the FISA judge was never
told that the dossier was bought and
paid for by the Clinton campaign in the
DNC a huge omissions mr. Schiff and
James Comey Andrew McCabe Sally Yates
Dana bent a-rod Rosenstein they're all
complicit in this because they at
different points all approved the
surveillance and the FBI then used this
Yahoo News article written by Michael
Isikoff about a quarter-page trip to
Russia to corroborate the phony dossier
the problem with that is the source for
the story for izikoff was Christopher
Steele so the FBI never corroborated the
information from two independent sources
and they presented it to the judge
like it was two sources corroborating
the same thing that was never the case
now as it relates to Steele he was also
suspended and terminated as an FBI
source for leaking to the media and the
memo also exposes how the demoted deal
J official Bruce or he maintained a
close relationship with steel and we
know that Bruce or had an office just
four doors down from Deputy Attorney
General rod Rosenstein and we know ORS
wife Nelly was working for fusion gps
Nelly was hired specifically well to
build that Trump dossier in other words
she was kind of paid by the Clintons if
you really look at it logically and as
the Daily Caller points out it sure does
seem like fusion GPS was trying to buy
influence in the Obama State Department
and Bruce or revealed that during
September 2016 Steele said he was quote
desperate desperate that Donald Trump
not get elected was passionate about
about him not being president
now the memo also exposes during the
initial application for the FISA warrant
then the head of the FBI's
counterintelligence ed the corroboration
of the steel dossier was in quote its
infancy stage in other words they knew
they hadn't verified this so you have an
unverified Clinton bought and paid for
dossier brought before a judge they
don't tell the judges Clinton bought and
paid for and they don't tell the judge
it wasn't verified this is outrageous
now we've also found out from fusion gps
founder glenn simpson he never bothered
to verify the document so the FBI lied
in that sense to the FISA Court judge
they never told him the truth they never
mentioned mentioned the dossier was
bought and paid for by Clinton and the
DNC they used the dossier filled with
Russian lies as we now learned in today
second memo as a justification as spy on
the Trump campaign and then an incoming
president what does that mean that means
America's powerful tools of intelligence
were unlawfully weaponized in one of the
biggest abuse of powers in the history
of this country and the media is
ignoring it and FISA laws were
manipulated by top ranking officials by
the way I want to be clear we love all
you FBI special agents we love the guys
in the intelligence community the rank
and file the people that save our lives
every day and put your lives on the line
we're not talking about rank and file
what we're talking about here the upper
echelon that we're trying to undermine
first a candidate and then a duly
elected president of the United States
think of
this James Comey testified under oath
the dossier was salacious and unverified
that he told that to the incoming
president yet Comey signed three FISA
applications that relied heavily on the
dossier even before he told Trump that
it was salacious and not verified why
would call me do that now Comey needs to
be hauled right back before Congress and
answer very important questions we put
on the side of your screen now Comey has
been more than happy to tweet out his
feelings every day he's writing a book
he'll probably be a TV pundit at CNN or
MSNBC any day he's willing to talk so
mr. Comey Jim why don't you go before
Congress and answer a lot of these
important questions here's another
important point the entire Russia
investigation they say was started
because of a drunken conversation former
Trump advisor I knew the Trump campaign
never heard of George papadopolis the
president said he never heard of him
that he had at a London bar with an
Australian diplomat that was in May then
according to the narrative two months
later when democratic emails started
leaking Australian officials then took
that information passed it on to
American intelligence agents so
apparently the threshold to launch an
investigation into an American citizen
through the FISA Court is that low all
you need is an FBI all they need is a
drunken four-way here set are you
kidding me